if we want to be a light to the world if
we think that democracy and liberty are
important virtues we need to get our own
house in order well here we are on the
Sunday special professor jonathan hight
of n wagon we're gonna get to all of my
questions about his brand new book the
coddling of the american mind which he's
written along with greg lukianov over at
that fire we'll get to all that stuff
plus the righteous mind all sorts of
great stuff but first let's talk about
your impending doom 71% of people say
they need life insurance but only 59%
have coverage which means at least 12%
of people are procrastinating and
another like 30% are idiots
sure normally procrastinating is a bad
thing but if you've been avoiding
getting life insurance procrastinating
may in this case have worked in your
favor because while you are putting off
getting life insurance policy genius was
making it easy policy genius is the easy
way to compare life insurance online you
can compare quotes in just five minutes
when it's that easy putting it off
becomes a lot harder you can compare
quotes while sitting on the couch
watching TV you can compare quotes while
listening to this podcast just try it
policy genius has helped over 4 million
people shop for insurance placed over
twenty billion dollars in coverage and
they don't just make life insurance easy
they compare disability insurance
renter's insurance health insurance if
you care about it they can cover it so
if you need life insurance but you've
been putting it off because it's too
confusing or you don't have the time
don't be a loser checkout policy genius
it's the easy way to compare top
insurers and find the best value for you
there's no sales pressure there's zero
hassle and it's free go check it out
what are you waiting for policy genius
calm when it's this easy to compare life
insurance why put it off
professor height thanks so much for
stopping by this is really a pleasure so
I want to start off by asking you sort
of some off-the-beaten-track questions
about your background I like to find out
where people are coming from before we
delve into their ideas so what exactly
is your you become very politicized a
lot of folks in politics very interested
in what you have to say your books were
first recommended to me by a
high-ranking Republican official what is
your political background where do you
stand politically and how did you get
there well I'm a totally stereotypical
Northeast Jewish liberal you know
academic type that's my background I
grew up hating well Richard Nixon my was
a little kid because I knew what you're
supposed to hate Nixon and then Reagan I
began studying cultural psychology in
graduate school looking at how
nations vary in their morale in their in
their moral worldviews and then as the
when the Democrats lost in 2000 and then
again in 2004 I began I was very upset
and I said I can't stand it that the
Democrats don't know how to talk about
morality and I can help them and so I
started converting my research over my
research from how countries vary - how
left and right very because by then left
and right in this country were becoming
like different countries with different
US history and even you know different
constitutions and so I committed to
understanding conservatives that I could
help explain conservative morality and
in the course of reading conservative
and libertarian philosophy and ideas I
realized oh my god you actually have to
look at problems from different
perspectives to understand them over
time I kind of stepped out I still talk
about the Republican Party later I have
very little good to say about the
Republican Party but I no longer
identify as being on any team I study
moral psychology I'm a social scientist
and I think as a social psychologist if
you're doing social science it's really
helpful to not be on a team to have the
independence to just try to study
problem so that's my background so as a
precursor to discussing some of the
issues you discuss in the coddling of
the American mind I think it's almost
necessary to talk about your earlier
book the righteous mind because that
sort of provides the intellectual
framework for what you talk about in the
new book so I wanted to ask you some
questions about about where that so to
fill in folks who may not have read the
book you make an argument that there are
a bunch of different moral axes along
which people work that people don't just
work along the idea of good and bad that
this breaks down into a number of
different categories and that left and
right see these categories differently
so what exactly are those moral axes and
how do they play into politics yeah so
from studying morality across cultures
and reading you know the Old Testament
and the Quran and reading ethnographies
from non-western societies it was really
clear that that everywhere you look
people understand like you know harm and
pain and suffering that that's a moral
issue and reciprocity and fairness
that's a moral issue everywhere but when
you go to other issues like respect for
authority
it's very common but some places are
really a gala terian and sort in-group
loyalty that's very common but some
places it's less important and then
that's
four axes are dimensions and then the
fifth one is sanctity or purity the idea
that's that the body is a temple it must
be protected from from degradation so
the kosher laws and Judaism are similar
in some ways to the hindu restrictions
on eating and prayer things like that so
it's a the theory that i developed based
in part on the ideas of richard shweder
my advisor at the university of chicago
was that the moral mind is like the way
the tongue has five different taste buds
on it for to pick up five different
chemical properties of the world our
minds it's as though they have five or
more different moral taste buds and
different religions different political
philosophies build a structure on some
of those what I found empirically from
doing research survey work in other
kinds of work is that people on the left
in America and in general in other
countries too
they build their morality mostly on
issues of care harm protection of the
vulnerable and then fairness but
fairness as a quality whereas social
conservatives they have those but they
see fairness more as proportionality do
the crime do the time that sort of thing
and then they also care a lot more about
group loyalty respect for authority and
a sense of sanctity or purity and if you
have that vocabulary those five moral
foundations you can understand why left
and right can't understand each other on
most cultural warrant issues and so what
that what that sort of implies and it's
underscored by the other point that you
making the righteous mind which the
people are largely driven by intuition
rather than how we like to think of
ourselves as reasonable creatures if
that's the case can there ever really be
any sort of conciliation in terms of
politics or is all of this sort of
chimeric all like there's no way to come
to it to it is sort of even conversation
right so so philosophically and
psychologically I am an intuitionist
that means I think intuition is where
the action is into it more our moral
intuitions come first and they drive our
reasoning afterwards that might make it
seem as though we therefore can't agree
because we're all just driven by gut
feelings but it's more complicated than
that because our intuitions come first
but they are educable they are
changeable we can't change each other's
intuitions just by throwing reasons you
know if left and right talking to each
other well you know don't you care about
you know respect for your parents you
can't just throw things at each other
but in relationships
we we come to listen to somebody we talk
with someone our minds can meld this is
an amazing ability that humans have that
no other animal has we can meld our
minds if we're open to that and then we
can actually hear each other and that's
what happened to me when I set out to
understand conservative thought I
actually met a few conservatives I'm
there were not many in my world but I
talked to some people they were very
decent people
so through relationships with the right
kind of relationships we actually can
open our minds and hearts a great novel
can do that a great ethnography can do
that and one of the tragedies are our
national life is that while we used to
be fairly mixed politically and we were
more separated racially in other ways
we've gotten more mixed along a lot of
axes but we're getting more and more
separate politically we live more in
more and more purified filter bubbles
and that makes it harder to empathize it
exacerbates our political divide and it
damages our democracy so that brings us
to the new book the coddling of the
American mind which really talks about
the ramifications of exactly this sort
of divide and in the in the coddling of
the American mind you talk about what
you'd consider three big problems in
American society today if you want to
just illuminate those that'd be
fantastic sure so the book is based
around three great untruths my first
book the happiness hypothesis was
actually about ten insights that you
find in ancient cultures all over the
world psychological insights and so one
of them is what doesn't kill you makes
you stronger
that was Nietzsche's formulation but you
find the exact same idea in mensches in
ancient China you find it all over the
world that kids need Challen beings need
challenge obstacles failure setback in
order to grow so that's a basic truth
that's a psychological truth but what
we're finding on campus we're finding in
the lives of American kids is an
increasing increasing presence of the
idea that what doesn't kill you makes
you weaker that is in fact oh my god
there's just just recently there's an
article making the rounds kids are
mobilizing in high school to to end the
practice of regular public speaking that
we you know some kids have anxiety
around public speaking that's very
common one of the article one of the
lines in this Atlantic article it quoted
a high school kids saying
nobody should be forced to do something
that they're not comfortable doing Wow
Wow can you imagine raising kids with
that dictum how would they come out if
this is true that we need challenges
setbacks even fear we have to be afraid
and overcome it and realize oh I can do
that and if we give in to this idea that
no one should be forced to do anything
they're uncomfortable doing we are
setting up the next generation for
failure and that's exactly our subtitle
how good intentions and bad ideas are
setting up a generation for failure more
briefly the second grade on truth is
always trust your feelings and the third
is life is a battle between good people
and evil people and our contention of
this in the book is that if we can
successfully teach the young generation
all three of these great untruths
they're almost guaranteed to fail well
let's talk about that that last one
because the last Bransford seems to me
the most dangerous one of all the
attempts to favor feelings I think have
a long subjective history and in some
ways may tie into the the intuition is
Amit you talked about earlier I mean
David Hume suggesting that basically we
are creatures of passion and then the
reason sort of rides on top pretending
but with that with all that said when it
comes to the question of you know people
seeing each other's good and evil do you
think that's bringing more from one side
of the Alvin then another do you how do
you see that that chain of causality
moving well let's hold off on the
question of who's to blame or who is
more guilty of this let's just start
with the basic psychology here which is
that human beings evolved for tribalism
this is actually our great secret but
you know chimpanzees hunting they have
had that they have troops and they
controlled territories so they're able
to do this they're able to have battles
between groups but humans are the
Masters of this and while that might
sound bad actually it enables us to
cooperate it enables us to have a shared
moral world so we are by nature tribal
and that's what got us into civilization
but modern liberal democracies are
brilliant at turning that down to allow
people to live more peacefully humans go
very quickly to tribalism but we can
also tone it down we're very good at
trade we're curious about other groups
as well and so
modern society is one that finds ways to
turn that down allow people to live near
others who are different from them with
no hostility no violence and we did a
pretty good job of that in the 20th
century and there was a huge wave
towards democracy so we made a lot of
progress in last few centuries
overcoming tribalism and the problem is
that it's so easy to turn it back on and
a lot of what's happening in our
politics between left and right that's
been accelerating since the 1990s cross
partisan hatred keeps going up and up
since the 1980s or 90s and unfortunately
now with certain forms of identity
politics we're finding these these
tensions between groups in the United
States and I just read there's a new
book out called the tribe something like
that in Britain very much the same
process is happening in the UK so this I
find very alarming that our our society
our politics social media are turning up
our tribalism so what do you think that
increased tribalism is coming from
because my theory would would be that
based on sort of Robert putnams believes
in in diversity of ethnicity being less
beneficial than for example solidarity
with regard to opinion meaning that
diversity is is great so long as we all
share a common goal but as if we don't
share a common goal than everything
fractures pretty quickly that the the
goal-oriented nature of the United
States a common culture that we shared
has basically disintegrated since the
1960s in some ways that's been for good
on issues of sex and race for example
but in some ways that's been quite bad
in terms of traditional morality in my
view the stuff that held the social
fabric together it seems like that's
what's been fraying most is the social
fabric and what that's done is its
thrust people back into the the
tribalism that you're talking about what
would you attribute the rise in
tribalism to yeah so the way that I
think about what's happened to our
country is that in a large secular
society there are a lot of forces
blowing us apart and they're a lot
pulling us together and if you go back
to the mid to late 20th century
everything was lined up to pull us
together we'd had extraordinarily high
rates of immigration in the late 19th
and early 20th century that's when my
grandparents came over from Russia and
Poland there was a big wave of
anti-immigrant backlash and in the 20s
the gates were shot immigration went way
down and as you say immigration has many
good effects
and many bad effects yet you have to
look at it honestly and try to maximize
the good so we had by the 70s and 80s we
had very low rates of foreign-born there
was a dominant culture it was the wasp
culture David Brooks has written
brilliantly about how the wasp setup a
meritocracy within which Jews and Asians
and other groups were able to succeed we
had a common enemy still in the Soviet
Union we had a functioning political
culture in Washington where there's a
lot of bipartisanship Oh in the media
system there were three networks and so
there was a more common common sources
of news so all those things were lined
up and this was the center of American
greatness and all over the world people
look to America and they said wow we
want what they've got let's copy their
Constitution let's copy their culture we
were the light of the world obviously
that's plenty of anti-americanism too
but there's a lot of admiration for us
and then one by one the the centrifugal
force is pulling us together began to
weaken the immediate environment
obviously reversed beginning with cable
TV all the way through to social media
now it's fractionating us the obviously
immigration greatly increased beginning
of the 60s and again many good things
The Economist's or clear integration is
good economically but as you say the
issues of social trust and cohesion
Robert putnams work and others suggest
that that that drops trust in others
drops and to have a functioning
democracy it really helps to have cross
group trust to not be suspicious of each
other so in so many ways things have
kind of turned around and we have to do
some serious thinking what is it going
to take to restore the the social
supports for an effective democracy I
mean I do wonder if one of the things
that it's gonna take is something that's
completely unpalatable to one side of
the political aisle at least and that is
a return to social institutions that
people don't like very much particularly
on the left so you I want to ask you
about that in just one second first
let's talk about your psychiatric health
today's show is sponsored by talk space
the online therapy company that lets you
message a licensed therapist from
anywhere at any time
all you need is a computer with internet
connection or the talk space mobile app
I'm a big advocate of if you need help
you need to talk to somebody and that
means you can improve your mental health
even if you had trouble making time for
it in the past
you can't imagine fitting anything else
in your life while the talks based
therapies is easiest
your therapist a message you need to get
something off your chest whenever you
need to well you do that with talk space
to talk about everyday challenges at
work or at home
chat about life there are no extra
commutes no leaving the office no
judgement remember therapy isn't just
about venting your innermost thoughts
digging into childhood memories it's
also about practical everyday strategies
that's the most important stuff for
stress management living a happy life
getting involved in in preventing your
own bad chains of mental thought having
a therapist simply provides you a
designated person for you to talk to
who's trained to listen and help you
make those positive changes all the
stigma that's associated with talking to
someone it's idiotic which is why you
should talk to my friends over at talk
space the talk space platform has over
2,000 licensed therapists who are
experienced and addressing life
challenges we all face to match for the
perfect therapist for a fraction of the
price of traditional therapy just go to
talk space.com slash Shapiro
use the code Shapiro to get forty five
bucks off your first month and show your
support for the show that's Shapiro and
talk space.com slash Shapiro for that
special deal go check it out right now
so sorry god I thought I spoke quickly
you are amazing oh thank you yeah they
won't if my career falls through I'll be
the guy at the end of the commercials
who issues all of the legal warnings so
if we were talking about the sort of
forces that need to come back together
it seems like there there are certain
forces that it's almost impossible to
bring back together and the ones that
most need to be brought back together
are the ones that maybe least palate but
what I mean by that to clarify is that
social fabric for 200 years of hundreds
of years throughout Western civilization
was basically based in church you found
your community in the church in the
synagogue you had a common
judeo-christian heritage and with the
rise of secularism which has come along
with a lot of economic benefits for sure
and a lot of diversity in terms of the
kinds of people who are treated well
there's also been a consummate decline a
consonant decline in the social fabric
that what's tearing people apart seems a
lot stronger than what's bringing us
together and it seems like that hole is
being filled by political tribalism I'm
gonna fill those values with whatever I
think my tribe is and it seems to me
particularly now to get to the
left-right issue and obviously I'm on
the right and I have plenty of
criticisms for the right but my main
criticism of the left these days is that
the left has fallen into a sort of
tribalism that refuses to even
acknowledge that another tribe exists or
that there's other there are other
people who perceive problems differently
so to go back to your discussion of the
various values in righteous mind you
suggest that basically the
political left bases itself on a couple
of values fairness and harm well if
those are the values you base yourself
upon then by necessity you have to be
implying even to yourself that the other
side is for unfairness and for harm that
in order for that there cannot be any
bridging of the gap because the only
values that matter are harm perceived as
anything bad that happens anything I
disagree with results in a certain
number of people getting hurt and
fairness in that person who disagrees
with me is in favor of the reinstitution
of a patriarchy or a hierarchical system
and you're spotting that evil everywhere
you look how can that possibly be
bridged without folks on the left
actually acknowledging that there are
other sets of values that they come into
play and that those ones actually drive
people and may not be in fact bad yeah
so I think what you're pointing to is an
asymmetry and mutual understanding and I
have evidence that that's that that's
true so I run a research site at your
morals org and we've had about a half a
million people go to there go there and
take our surveys and in one experiment
we had people take our basic instrument
the moral foundations questionnaire
which it gives you a score on these five
foundations and we had one third of the
people just filled it out fist them
cells one third we're told please fill
this out as the typical liberal and
progressive would one third were told to
fill it out as a typical conservative
what we found is that moderates are able
to correctly predict how everybody would
fill it out conservatives were almost as
good as moderates and it was people on
the left especially the far left were
very inaccurate and it's for precisely
the reason that you say that because
they couldn't see these questions about
loyalty and fairness and sanctity they
they couldn't see those as moral virtues
so on the questions about harm and
fairness they said well conservatives
don't care about cruelty to animals and
children so I do think and this was my
case too you know I was very well
educated in the United States which
means I learned nothing about
conservatism I learned very little about
a large portion of political philosophy
and so it's impossible to grow up in
this country without knowing what the
left believes through the media through
newspapers through movies but I do agree
that the left often fails to understand
the right and this is why we parentally
have these issues on the Left where my
god we
how you know how could they have voted
from I don't know anybody who voted that
way what were they thinking and so
political surprises tend to be where the
left is surprised they're there and as
happened in brexit there I think they
have a harder time understanding
conservatives than vice-versa
I personally think that every high
school civics class not that they teach
them much anymore but high school civics
class should include the best of
progressive thinking the best of
conservative thinking possibly
libertarian too we shouldn't we
shouldn't encounter political diversity
through the lens of the worst because
social media guarantees if you're on one
side you are force-fed constant stories
of the outrages by the most outrageous
horrible people on the other side and if
that's your view of who they are
of course you don't trust them of course
you don't want your legislators to
compromise so I think we need to
understand we are coming apart in this
country we are faced in the actual
danger of the dissolution of the country
over the next 10 20 years
I'm not saying it's likely to happen I
think it's not likely to happen but it
is possible in ways that none of us
thought we're coming or a possible five
or ten years ago so I think we need to
take this seriously
start educating beginning in high school
for more political tolerance respect and
mutual understanding so when it comes to
the sort of pessimism that you're
expressing about the nature of the
country with which I fully agree there
are a bunch of people who do disagree
there are folks like Steven Pinker who's
claiming that everything is getting
better there are a lot of folks on the
Left who have suggested that problems on
campus which we discuss at length and
the coddling of the American mind that
these are exaggerated that basically
campuses are just fine that there's
tolerance for other points of view how
do you respond to to those particular
criticisms one that everything is
getting better and is just fine
generally and two that college campuses
are hunky-dory except for a few weird
sort of yeah straying from the mean all
right great questions let's take the
first one so Steve Pinker I think is
brilliant I think he in the big picture
I'm pretty confident he's right that if
we were just to check in at hundred year
intervals each hundred years things
would be much better than the hundred
years before now of course at some point
we might see the smoking wreckage of a
global nuclear war but odds are he's
right in the long run but as he grants
and as Robert Reich granted in his book
non zero years ago you can have some big
setbacks it's only within the big
picture that you see that the March
grass but along the way you can have
some pretty bad stuff happening and I
think where we are now a lot some of our
problem is caused by social media
of course these problems of polarization
were getting worse before social media
but social media is really messing
things up all around the world
odds are we'll learn how to deal with it
as we've learned how to deal with junk
food it took decades before we could
learn how to live with the constant
presence of junk food I heard that for
the first time last year the obesity
rate in America actually went down a
tiny bit so maybe we've learned how to
coexist and maybe that will happen with
social media but a lot of bad stuff can
happen along the way in terms of what's
going on on campus there's been a really
productive debate as an excellent debate
started by some political scientists in
Canada Jeff Sachs who pointed out that
if you look at the the general social
survey attitudes about free speech it's
not changing in fact if anything younger
people are more tolerant and so that
pushed me and Greg and others to refine
our claims and that's the way it's
supposed to work and what we what we
found is we dug into the data is yes
this National Survey data shows no drop
but that's because it's focused on
Millennials and this book our book the
coddling of the American mind is not
about Millennials the Millennials are
fine on free speech it's the generation
after the Millennials it's the kids born
in 1995 and after they were raised very
different than we'll come back to that
cuz that's a major topic to talk about
so if you just look at IGN or Gen Z and
you grant the point that the skeptics
made that there are 4,500 colleges in
this country or institutions of a high
rate of some sort are all of them up in
arms over conservative speakers no most
of them are not most of them don't have
concert decks they don't you know the
commuter schools they don't bring in
lecturers they don't have riots so if
you look at nationally representative
data on most campuses nothing is
happening if you go home to a family if
you have a job off-campus you're not
going to develop this arcane morality
that will talk about this safety as a
morality however if you look at
especially in the Northeast and the west
coast if you look at the elite schools
there as far as I can tell this new
culture is present at almost all of the
schools it's not an engineering school
so much its dominant in the humanities
so
varies even within the universities my
point is there's a lot of diversity this
is not we should not have a moral panic
where we say the new generation is lost
something's eaten their brains or
colleges are going up in flames that's
not true but there is a new morality
that is present in parts of most maybe
all elite schools on the coast that's
where the shout downs and and what
little violence there's been that's
where that takes place so we have to
refine the story figure out what's
happening and I think figure out how to
how to reverse this cultural shift
because it leads to a culture that's
really bad for the students themselves
in the mental health and it's really bad
for a culture of free inquiry
so how indicative are those outlier
schools statistically of a broader trend
across young folks that's yeah that's
complicated to answer in terms of broad
trends across young folks they're one
the most important one the one that I
think guarantees that we will be
attending to this for many years to come
we cannot sweep this under the rug is
that rates of anxiety and depression are
rising quickly for kids born after 1995
it's rising across social classes across
races not so much across genders or
rather I should say it's things are
getting worse for boys substantially but
for girls it's several times were
several times faster the increase and
what's very important understand because
there's debate around this some people
say oh you know kids they like to say
they're depressed they're comfortable
with this language there was a not that
there was a not been the New York Times
last couple weeks ago by a psychiatrist
saying oh you know it's not real it's
just changing diagnostic categories no
because if you look their studies we
cite them in the book if you look at
hospital admission data this is the
number of kids admitted because they cut
their body with something sharp and had
to be admitted to a hospital it shows
exactly the same pattern as it does for
depression anxiety that is its way up
it's up even for the 11 to 13 year olds
and it's up especially for girls and
then you look at the suicide data
this is CDC data federal data same thing
the boys suicide rate for teenage boys
from the first decade of the 20th
century first century to the last couple
years it begins going up around
2010-2011 its top 20
85% 25% more dead boys by their own hand
over the last 10 10 or so years for
girls the increases 70% 7 zero so this
is not just some isolated thing on a few
college campuses we have a mental health
crisis across social classes across all
the different divides on the elite
college campuses this is contributing to
a culture of protectiveness we're
vulnerable or at least even if I'm not
involved well she's vulnerable he is
vulnerable I am standing up for them we
can't have Ben Shapiro talk here for
example and this is where the
microaggression culture comes in the
idea of speeches violence which was
chanted at me proposed at Berkeley which
is it which is an insane concept just on
the face of especially at Berkeley yeah
it's it's it's pretty wild over there
but and what was really wild about that
one is the the radical shift because I
had spoken there the previous year with
no violence whatsoever the next year I
required 500 police officers for
protection for some odd reason but what
exactly does this trend hold true across
parenting styles across cultures or is
it or is it just a subsection that we're
really talking about yeah
so this is also new that I I can't give
you a solid answer we don't have data on
this what we we do in a section in the
book we did spend some time researching
social class differences because we know
there's a huge amount of research on
social class differences in parenting
and we read two really good books
Annette Lareau
has a book called unequal childhoods and
Robert Putnam um has a book called our
kids and they both come to the same
conclusion which is that differences by
race and parenting are actually fairly
small once you control for class so
upper middle-class black parents are
more similar to upper middle-class white
parents than they are to working-class
of either sex and so working-class
parents do give their kids less
supervision which is good part of the
problem is in the 90s we took away most
of kids on supervised time by the ages
or 90s we stopped letting kids out to
play without supervision
it's fearing but they we thought they'd
be abducted or something like that so
the working class is not as
overprotective
now working-class kids have a lot of
other problems they face a lot more
trauma a lot more threat like real
trauma like physical trauma relational
trauma but in this country right now at
elite schools there was some breeze
came out last year at many of our top
schools there are more kids we're
children of the top 1% income then the
bottom 60% so our elite schools are
populated overwhelmingly by the top few
percent of the income distribution and
that's part of it rich kids have a lot
more time to do symbolic politics
working-class kids they have to pay
their they have to pay their tuition
they have a lot of other obligations so
the the culture of safety isms to be
especially intense in upper-middle class
upper class elite coastal communities
when it comes to the identity politics
that's cropped up so recently and and
you sort of classify as a subset of
emotional tribal driven politics where
is the identity politics issue coming
from doesn't have deep roots or shallow
roots and is it really just a new form
of the kind of tribalism you've been
talking about so so here so let me make
a point here which I hope will be
helpful to your audience in this country
we're in the middle of a long-running
culture war in which terms become they
get tagged and they get used either as a
tax or defense is an identity politics
and social justice or two of those terms
and you know our my you know I work on a
college campus Greg and I work on
college campuses we really want to solve
the problem we don't want to score
points we don't want to bash people we
really want to solve the problem my view
from writing the righteous mind is that
whenever you have a a political movement
there's always something that it that
they're right about there's always
something that is good or true about it
and so what we did with identity
politics you know cuz I came in very
suspicious of it thinking you know this
is probably a bad thing but as we read
about it we realized okay you know what
you have to have identity politics if if
people can organize because they're wine
growers in California they can form a
group to advocate for the rights of wine
growers in California and you know and
chess players can I mean you can have
you know politics should be responsive
to every possible interest group
why can't gay people or LGBTQ weic weick
an african-american of course every
group can organize so you can't say
identity politics is bad what you need
to do is say okay in
in the current American context how are
you pursuing the aims of your group and
this I think is a distinction that I
found just clarified things right away
you can either pursue it using a common
humanity approach which is exactly what
Martin Luther King Pauli Murray a lot of
the early civil rights activists did
common humanity you start by saying
listen my brothers and sisters or you
you use this soaring American language
as he didn't as I have a dream speech
you you you first establish we we
Americans we human beings they used a
lot of religious language they a
Christian language but it's obviously
judeo-christian language you start that
way and now right away you're already
halfway down the road to success because
now you're talking to people as members
of a common group and you can say some
of our brothers and sisters are being
denied access to dignity to jobs so that
worked even if of course there was
resistance at the time it calls on our
better angels it established the
connection and in the long run it works
that we think is great what's new or at
least what's it newly intense on college
campuses in the last just a few years is
what we call the common enemy form of
identity politics it's based on the idea
that Bedouin proverb me against my
brother me and my brother against our
cousin me my brother and cousin against
the stranger and if you unite everybody
on campus against the enemy and the
enemy is on campus to because the enemy
is straight white males so what's new is
the idea of intersectionality which as
we say in the book intersectionality is
not a bad idea the idea that identities
interact that being a black woman is not
just the sum of the two but there are
special special obstacles that black
women face that's a fine idea that's
right and true but the way that it gets
implemented on campus is to train
students to see look around oh you know
a female white and to see okay female is
oppressed male there's a presser white
is a presser black is oppressed so see
people in binary dimensions to to to to
imagine
trying to create a diverse environment
on a college campus you're trying to
create diversity and at the same time
you're telling people to judge others
through this simple binary bipolar
dimension good bad good bad to make
moral judgments of people so
intersectionality as it's practiced on
many campuses amounts to trying to unite
a coalition of victim groups against the
evil straight white males and this is a
recipe for in addition to miss
diagnosing the nature of not just
American society but especially college
campuses it trains students to it's
trained students to be man icky and it
trains them to approach life and
relationships through the lens of good
and evil we've got to tone that down if
we want a successful diverse society
isn't there a deeper critique of
identity politics even than that because
you're taking identity politics at sort
of its most favorable level to say
people feel an identity with for example
I feel identity with other Jews but to
suggest that all Jews are necessarily in
the same boat which is sort of the basis
of identity politics for you to group
yourself with a group of people is to
imply a common enemy of some sort that's
so should should we be fighting harder
against identity politics than even
you're saying in other words let's not
group ourselves as blacks or Jews or
gays let's let's group ourselves as a
group of individuals who all agree on
these common principles of how the
society ought to be governed and how we
ought to be left alone yes I certainly
agree with you on that that to what
extent should we encourage people to see
themselves as members of identity groups
or should we encourage them to think
that black people are a certain way Jews
are a certain way I think one of the
great triumphs in the last few centuries
has been to create a world that was
especially clear for Jews
you know Jews were literally kept in
ghettos and it wasn't until the
Enlightenment ideas finally spread the
Jews are allowed to make lives for
themselves the liberal tradition is
ultimately about long room for people to
make the lives that they want it can
choose to identify with a group or not a
really encouraging sign is that over the
last few years a lot of people who are
not straight white males have been have
been told you need to identify this way
and they're they're saying like no I
don't how dare you tell me how dare you
tell me how I should feel
and at first it was maybe hard for them
to say
but in the last year a lot are saying it
and so there's all these great books
that now Francis Fukuyama has a new book
just came out about identity and dignity
Anthony Appiah has been writing
beautifully about this Amy Amy Chua
political tribes so we're finding and
there's a lot more so I think this is
very encouraging America is a diverse
country there are a lot of intellectuals
in every different possible identity
category and a lot of them are rejecting
this binary you're in or out kind of
identity well politically doesn't this
tend toward libertarianism just
naturally because the what you're really
talking about on a political level is we
all have an agreement about the basic
things that we should all do together
and then everybody should basically be
left alone to identify how they how they
please how does this play out
politically in terms of you know if you
were taking two straight party politics
so you know as I hear you talk what I'm
thinking is that's really the definition
of liberal and what I mean is the word
liberal its origins are you believe in
Liberty its origins are originally you
know if the liberal arts are the skills
needed to be a free person in an open
society and so that's when we talk about
liberal arts schools we talk about the
liberal tradition that's what it means
and so that's that in that sense I'm a
liberal
now I stopped using the word as the Left
began to kind of split between what I
like to think of is there's the liberal
left and then there's the illiberal left
most professors in my opinion are
liberal left they are uncomfortable with
many forms of identity politics but it's
the illiberal left that has has had the
loudest voice it's it's often dangerous
as you found as many people about it's
dangerous to stand up against them
dangerous then I shouldn't I here I go I
shouldn't talk about D you you'll get a
lot of blowback and a lot of hatred I
swear I should say at times dangerous
I've had actually from time to time I've
had wear bulletproof vests so yeah
that's occasionally dangerous occasion
but you're right I mean and I've said
many times that the best I speak on
dozens of campuses it's really only a
couple of year that are a serious
problem but yes and that's great just
the abit this is right this is one of
the things we most need in this
polarized time just just that little bit
of nuance that you just added that goes
so far if we can just leave whenever
we're having these conflicts these talk
just to acknowledge anything about the
other side and then you can make your
critique I think that's just listeners
everywhere this is the way to be more
effective if you don't believe me read
Dale Carnegie how to win for
influence people this is the number one
technique so but your question was is
does that mean we should be libertarian
and I guess I would say it ought to mean
that we should be liberal in the
traditional sense unfortunately the
libertarians are sort of left as the
guardians of the of the liberal
traditions so what what do you think has
been the response to all of your
research which has been a lot friendlier
to that to the right than a lot of other
things that have been said in sociology
departments around the country how
people react in the Academy to you
because we've seen cases ranging from
Evergreen State College to Northwestern
were to Yale with the Christakis is
where people are legitimately run out of
jobs become witch-hunts in the book
what's what's been the reaction to your
work have you got anything for blowback
no I have not nothing bad has happened
to me you know other than you know I
occasionally get horribly nasty tweets
and I got an email the other day which
was from an anonymous server and it was
just a string of obscenities which I
can't even say on camera I mean yes yeah
so other than strangers nothing bad has
happened to me and I think this is
actually very important to point out so
when I started critiquing the left from
the left you know there were some people
are suspicious of me but a lot of people
realized you know the left we do have
problems we do need this critique and
because I would do it in a sort of a
gentle way and because I clearly was not
on the right so I think I moved up to
sort of the edge of what was possible
nothing bad ever happened to me then
when I stepped out and I started saying
I'm not on the left anymore I'm just on
nothing I'm not on a team again I
thought there'd be blowback and some
people were suspicious some people
didn't like me but nothing bad happened
to me and then when Greg and I wrote our
Atlantic article critiquing this new
culture on campus and it is a critique
of a certain kind of identity politics
you know my wife said John are we gonna
have to like hide our address like are
people gonna stalk us nothing bad
happened to us because by 2015 people
all over the place were beginning
realize something weird is happening
were puzzled and if you come out with an
explanation of like here's what we think
is happening people are really curious
and now with this book again I was
actually kind of afraid like you know
what's gonna happen to me I have tenure
I'm not gonna lose my job but left
what's gonna happen to me socially and
the reception has been overwhelmingly
positive because again people realize
something is mess
stop you know the mental health crisis
is real something's going on
so yeah it's and this is I guess my
advice to people is if you speak up in
this polarized climate we were a lot of
us are afraid to speak up but if you can
do it in a respectful way with just a
little bit of nuance the blowback is
often much less than you then you would
expect so you teased much earlier in the
show that you have a lot of critiques of
the Republican Party because I am of
course I'm a conservative that means we
spend most of this program critiquing
leftists on campus and some of the head
of rising leftist ideas of identity
politics intersectionality
microaggressions and such so what are
your main critiques of the right how
could the right be doing a better job
and what exactly is the right doing
deeply wrong right now well you know so
what really attracted me to conservatism
was reading the philosophy so in one of
my gateway drugs was Thomas solo
I read conflict of visions and boy that
book when I assigned it to my classes at
UVA you know that really opened people's
eyes and he talks about are you do you
have to constrain view of human nature
which is where you think people if you
take off the constraints they're gonna
do selfish greedy sexual aggressive
things and we need religion family law
versus the unconstrained vision which
goes back to Rousseau or it's it's it's
the John Lennon song imagine just knock
down all the walls remove religion and
country everything will be great um you
know what you when I look at it that way
as a social scientist I have to say the
conservatives are right about human
nature that is the correct view of human
nature and that goes back to our early
part of our conversation about how we
need structures we need constraints in
order to flourish so I'm very attracted
to a lot of conservative philosophy and
that goes all the way up you know from
Burke all the way through Sol you know
and Hayek and others were conservative
libertarian so I'm attracted to a lot of
the philosophy and of course I disliked
Ronald Reagan and the Republican Party
back then when I was a partisan Democrat
but I can see the wisdom of of fomenting
dynamism of I can see the wisdom of a
lot of what the Republican Party was
doing that and George HW Bush was a very
very decent man but I look at the
Republican parties well since Newt
Gingrich I think converted to a much
more confrontational party which again I
can't create a
that the Democrats didn't treat the
Republicans well when they were in the
majority but I think Newt Gingrich and
Fox News created an environment in which
in which the Republicans were more
incentivized to sort of go rogue to
develop an India - - based on feedback
and and opportunities to be more radical
and I think some of the policies that
they've implemented the worst critique
of the Republican Party or what common
critique is all they seem to really care
about is lowering taxes on the rich that
seems to be their top priority and that
that's been true for a while and so a
party that is just focused on its
relationship with its donor class and
then its ability to do things you know I
don't well don't get me started on Trump
but the things that Trump is doing to
destroy our alliances to disrespect our
allies while sucking up to dictators and
the fact that the Republican Party has
not repudiated him so I think that Trump
clearly is not a conservative he is
appealing much more to authoritarian
tendencies then there's I can't see I
can't see any lineage from Edmund Burke
to Donald Trump there is there's no way
to get from here to there so the fact
that the Republican Party has lost its
conservative soul I think has fallen
Donald Trump is I think a mark of
damnation that it will wear for many
decades we quote research in the book on
how however the political world looks
between the ages of 14 and 24 sticks and
so I think the Republican Party is
signing I can't say it's death warrant
but I think it's going to lose a
generation of the young people now they
will vote more democratic for the next
50 years
I mean I'd to agree with that assessment
which is one of my great fears about
president Trump before he was president
Trump was that the I listed several
fears about President Trump that I had
in my chief one which I think is still
on the table as the toxification of
conservatism thanks to all of this with
that said is there any way to put the
political genie back in the bottle
because it seems like political leaders
of both sides have a real interest in
revving up the culture wars and I think
that when it comes to you know
Republican legislative priorities it has
less to do with the stuff they'd like to
do and the stuff that they can actually
do without blowback so tax cuts are
popular because who exactly is gonna
whine about them everyone at least got a
check right and when it comes to the
left
but if a debt and the deficit which
Republicans were the watchdog's of and
for the last 20 years they've been the
bad guys well I I totally agree with
that but the point is that there's the
stuff that people can get done in
Congress then there's the stuff that
people can jabber about in Congress and
by looking to our politicians as our
moral leaders by looking to our
politicians as our philosophical leaders
what we've actually done is create the
the sort of room for this divide between
practical politics and the stuff that we
think that they ought to be saying
philosophically when the politicians are
seen as as thought leaders Barack Obama
was seen as a thought leader for the
left and then he implements a bunch of
policies that are completely partisan I
mean he has no bipartisan legislation
throughout any of his tenure and yet he
is seen by the left as some sort of
great bipartisan unifier and and the
right responds by saying okay fine we'll
just put somebody up there who doesn't
pretend to be bipartisan we'll just go
out there and he'll do whatever he wants
is there any way to put this genie back
in the bottle because there is money to
be made and votes to be gained in the
sort of tribalism that both of us are
sort of railing against you well first I
have to defend Obama he came out so if
you go back to the first election the
economic crisis threatened us with ruin
nobody knew was gonna happen it was a
really scary time ten years ago and
Obama did the right thing which is to
say we're gonna do this bipartisan this
is not a partisan thing we're gonna do
this bipartisan and we have to do this
together and he and going back to his
2004 speech I believe that Obama really
does he does actually understand
conservatives better than most he lived
in Indonesia he's traveled a lot I think
Obama I like him philosophically and he
can't started the right way the
Republicans however there was a
particular retreat they had early in
Obama's in the first couple months of
his term it summer in Maryland may I
Cameron Bure it was and they did a
calculation and they said should we work
with him and try to make him successful
or should we try to make him fail which
will work better for us and they
correctly calculated that the second
course was best for them and that was
Obama's fault because Obama was very bad
at negotiating Obama should have said
again this is my my political analysis
which is not worth much Obama should
have said back-channel we're gonna do
this bipartisan you have three months to
join me on it if you don't join me
I'm gonna break your knees I'm gonna
blame it all on you and we're gonna do
it my way
but because Obama didn't play hardball
and he did this internationally -
because he didn't know how to negotiate
and have a tough side the Republicans
correctly calculated that they could
roll him but they could they could make
him fail and it worked
they came sweeping into power two years
later so I can't fault Obama Obama
didn't come in trying to be you see and
then also on the health insurance yeah
it was
he got no Republican votes but he tried
and tried and tried to take a Republican
idea from Mitt Romney for how to do
health reform so Obama tried and it was
this hyper partisan Republican party
that I think drove him ultimately to
have to just do it in a partner
obviously I would disagree with that
political analysis almost in full but I
do think that election 2012 was
basically in my view sort of the
breaking of the country because by
election 2012 there was a belief on the
right that Mitt Romney was a decent guy
who was pretty moderate and a lot of his
politics the only one would ever
provided Obamacare for a state and then
he was torn apart and savaged as a bad
guy and exactly the same way the left
savages Donald Trump except that Mitt
Romney is not Donald Trump and so we've
now been locked into this mutual Rock'em
Sock'em robots combat where it's a lot
easier to punch the other guy than to
have a conversation with them so how do
we get beyond all this because obviously
you proposed a lot of solutions and
coddling up the American mind you talk
about solutions a lot how do we get
beyond all of this even based on the
original premise of righteous mind which
is that we are mostly intuitional for
mostly intuitional how do the the lizard
brain is extraordinarily strong with us
how do we get past that and exercise
reason or does reason exist what
facility do we use to move beyond is
it's very difficult to just decide to
change the forces the historical trends
that God is in to this rising
polarization are complicated they're a
lot of them there's no one thing we can
turn around and change I think the most
basic thing we need to do is we need to
have some major reforms of our political
institutions to encourage more
moderation compromise and cooperation in
Congress and at other levels of
government what I'm hoping would happen
this is an idea from from Norm Ornstein
who wrote the book it's even worse than
it looks at political scientists is at
some point the next president somebody
will say okay
we're in big trouble here everybody
hates Congress Congress doesn't want to
be hated
let's have let's have let's have a panel
recommend a sweeping set of changes to
make the legislative process more
effective to stop - we can't be shutting
out the the minor party entirely we
can't be having well for the filibusters
going away for a lot of reasons so we
have to have reform - the way Congress
works the way elections are run the
closed party primary really incentivizes
extremists to run because that's how you
win the nomination so some states are
experimenting with open primaries or
with top two primaries as you have here
in California so I think we need a whole
package of political reforms for
Congress the issue of the media and
social media reforms they are much
harder there I don't really know there
are tweaks that Facebook and Twitter can
do to their algorithms YouTube videos
but all I can think of is tweaks that
it's very hard to change to change the
media environment education we've
already talked about we need to be
educating kids for democracy we're not
doing that one of the suggestions we
make in the book is that however bad
things are the young generation which
has had very little time to work out
problems they've been given very little
freedom and independence when the
current generation i gen or Gen Z when
they reach their the age of political
power things might get a lot worse
because they haven't worked out the
skills of compromise dispute resolution
on their own so I think we're in big
trouble and we're gonna have to take a
comprehensive look at how we raise
children how we educate them in high
school in college how our political
institutions work I've done what I can
Greg and I've done what we can in our
book this is gonna take a collaboration
among political scientists and
historians to really focus as we're
focusing on other threats to the country
I'm to really focus on the threats to
our democracy without blaming one side
or the other
saying the system is messed up if we
want to be a light to the world if we
think that democracy and liberty are
important virtues we need to get our own
house in order and this is I think where
you know I D / a really deep solution is
gonna require a rebuilding of a social
fabric that has almost nothing to do
with politics and when we watch the
social fabric torn apart on everything
from sneakers to football it seems very
difficult to put all of
back together I think they eat it seems
to me that bipartisan legislation is not
gonna make everybody feel better about
everything it seems like the whatever
whatever legislative remedies are sought
to various problems just because you got
a Democrat and Republican shaking hands
it doesn't heal the problem what we have
here is that neighbors don't trust each
other neighbors don't see each other in
any social setting neighbors don't if
the only thing that we have in common is
government we have nothing in common
that's right so is so how do we rebuild
but we spend some time on individual
parenting you're a parent obviously you
have a 12 year old an 8 year old I'm a
parent with two kids under five what's
the best way to educate your kids to be
part of that social fabric to rebuild
democracy from the ground up in every
generation so we have a whole chapter on
play and why play is so important for
the development of any human being and
why play basically lets you practice the
skills of democracy when Alexis de
Tocqueville traveled in America in 1831
he was so impressed
he said you know in in France if some
great thing needs to be done it's gonna
be done by the the monarch and in
England it's gonna be done by the
aristocrats but in America if they need
to build a bridge or start a hospital
they get a bunch of people together they
form an association Americans have a
genius for the art of Association he
said and we cite research in the book on
how play is the practice for the art of
Association a pickup soccer game three
kids sitting around what should we do
this afternoon I don't know what do you
want to do and then they figure it out
jointly so so what I'm with my kids it's
hard because all the parents are
overprotective including us when we try
to send our kids out like we send them
out to go do an errand go across the
street my son would say but daddy
everybody looks at me funny because
there no other kids out there so it's a
social coordination problem I'm hopeful
that Americans will realize we have a
mental health catastrophe we've got to
do something forget politics we've got
to do something for the well-being of
our kids so I urge you I urge every
every viewer every listener go to let
grow dot-org
it's an organization started by leonora
skin AZ who wrote the book free-range
kids I'm on the board and has all kinds
of suggestions for how you can make your
neighborhood and your elementary school
and all your schools how you can make
them better able to support free-range
child rearing kids having
a few hours a day in which there's not
an adult watching them how you can get
administrators to back off and give them
more room so we have a lot of ideas
there for how you can address the
problems from childhood up through a
high school next we have to look at all
of our institutions all the places that
we congregate and so let's talk about so
religious congregations workplaces
universities beginning a year or two ago
I started getting calls or hearing from
you know CEO is saying we're being torn
apart Oh battles over bathrooms battles
over this or a lot of the identity
politics issues which again have to be
solved but that if you do it in the
common enemy way it's impossible to
solve
so leaders of almost any organization or
have our facing these problems my rabbi
I go to central synagogue in Manhattan
my rabbi you know when a rabbi speaks it
says anything about Israel oh my god
like you know a third of the
congregation is gonna revolt whichever
way you go so leadership now is really
really hard my team we developed a
wonderful program called open mind so I
urge our jurors go to open mind platform
org we've created a program runs on any
app it's free and any any platform it's
free in which it walks you through some
basic moral psychology in a sense it
kind of walks you through the righteous
mind and some other social psychology
about why the you point diversity is
good for you makes you smarter it makes
you better able to deal with people why
it's so hard to do that how do you talk
to people how do you talk to people who
different and our belief our hope and we
have some evidence is that if any group
takes this training it only takes about
an hour and a half um
if any group does this training whenever
whenever problems come up they'll be
they'll have be better skilled they'll
have a common vocabulary they'll be able
to resolve it so I think we need to see
this as a national crisis rising
polarization which is making all of our
institutions less functional my fear is
that if the Nike gambit pays off for
Nike more companies will do that we'll
have red and blue restaurants red and
blue you know dentists will everything
will be politics all the time my god
what a nightmare that will be so we all
have to take responsibility for this and
it starts with us as individuals and
then steps right
away from us as individuals into every
organization or institution that we're
part of we can all be part of the
solution at that more local level I do
have one final question and that final
question will be what is best-case
scenario for the country in 20 years
what's worst-case scenario for the
country in 20 years but if you want to
hear the answer from Jonathan height you
have to be a daily wire subscriber to
subscribe go to daily wire comm click to
subscribe you can hear the end of our
conversation there well Jonathan Hyde
thank you so much for stopping by
injecting a note of reason into our
insane political discourse it really is
a pleasure to have him and wanting to do
it for months really appreciate exam
thanks so much for having me off the
bench Bureau shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy Boren associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens edited by Alex Singaram audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Jess wah
Alvaro and title graphics by Cynthia and
Gullu ben shapiro shows sunday special
is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright ford publishing
[Music]